Audiences have embraced wakanda and black panther
and chadwick  he knew exactly what this
store what these images meant to the world
we all suffered an incredible loss when
we lost Chadwick Chad was very much our
artistic partner I would spend time with him
just he and I talking about where we want to
see the story go how much he admired to other
characters and the actors that portrayed them
and the telling of this story you were all
able to honor him together it was really
moving to come back to wakanda and for us to
be able to do it with a sense of Celebration
there's so much that's happening in this movie
it's amazing so many new characters to explore
just seeing the world of wakanda again and then
now we're going to this whole new world underwater
my name is a character we were really excited
to portray in the film arguably one of the
oldest comic book characters that there is the
opportunity to play a character like this it's a
dream he's the king of an underwater civilization
called talucan he is regarded as a living God
I need to know if wakanda is an ally or an
enemy the level of care creating this story
it is astounding and so it just really felt
like for all of us to give it everything we
have and more I'm just so grateful and
blessed to be a part of this the actors
were filled with emotion and passion I am queen
a female whole nation and my entire family is
gone all together we ended up using those
feelings to create something really special
the action and adventure with the emotional
Stakes so high things are happening up down
and everywhere I'm so excited about the
world being able to tap into wakanda again
how each character takes on new challenges
and I'm excited about us honoring Chad
yeah he would want us to just Inspire the world
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my new black panther wakanda forever trailer
video there's a whole bunch of new footage they
talk a lot about the movie so we'll break it down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course I'll
be doing a bunch of videos for the movies we get
a little bit closer as me posting this video we
don't have long to wait in talking about the
killmonger of it all yes they are bringing
killmonger back might not be quite the way people
expect it to be but if you theorize that he might
show up through the ancestral plane as Force ghost
killmonger they are actually doing a version of
that I believe all these scenes where everything
is on fire in the throne room here and there's
water all around like it's after this big attack
I believe these scenes are taking place inside the
ancestral plane and I think the idea is that
instead of getting guidance from t'chall like
she's looking for t'challa in the ancestral plane
but instead she winds up finding killmonger and
he gives her the advice that she needs in becoming
the next Black Panther so he winds up influencing
her take on the Black Panther character which I
think is one of the reasons why her black panther
suit looks so much like killmonger suit with all
the gold highlights on it we get a little bit more
footage of them talking about namor a few more
scenes with his character in the way that they
contextualize him as a mutant in the MCU like
what's going on with him and how close is he
going to be to the comics he has some new dialogue
he says my enemies call me Namor he pronounces it
a little bit differently himself like he says
no more just because they're changing a little
bit about the backstory of him and his people like
they're from MCU Atlantis in the comics but in my
previous videos I've talked about how they wanted
to change that a little bit so that it's not quite
so similar to MCU Aquaman's backstory like in
the comics Aquaman's father is human his mother
is Atlantean it's kind of the same deal for Namor
his father is a human his mother is an Atlantean
even though Namor did come before Aquaman in the
comics and I love the way they reference that in
this featurette too they basically say he's one of
the first comic book characters ever in the comics
they refer to namor as the first mutant because
in the real life history of comic books just in
general in like real life chronology he is the
first mutant character that ever debuted in the
comics now in the context of the movie in the MCU
timeline he might not be the very first mutant to
have ever been born on planet Earth it'll be
interesting to see the way they develop that
just because there's so many other mutant based
characters they're introducing through Marvel
Phase 5 and Marvel Phase 6 as we head up to the
new X-Men movie some of them will be like Namor
and Miss Marvel who were born on MCU planet Earth
like 616 Earth and some will be like Deadpool and
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine and they'll come from
the Multiverse I know there's a whole bunch of
questions about Deadpool 3 like where does it
fit into the MCU because they're technically
from the fox Marvel Universe but there's all
this Multiverse stuff going on during Marvel
phase four they said that that movie is going to
be an MCU movie like it will be connected to the
MCU but because Deadpool Is So Meta like so fourth
wall breaking and he calls out so many big tropes
I expect him to make a bunch of jokes about the
timelines again like he did in the first Deadpool
movie like which timeline are we in this is so
confusing which Cinematic Universe are we in this
is ridiculous okay this looks fun enough in the
last days of fox fire sale kind of way not sure
if it was worth diverting Canadian cumberbatch's
little mind away from my next movie or any tips
on getting into the MCU there cork just expect
him to make a bunch of jokes about that because
he's already referenced coming into the MCU in
that Deadpool and Korg video so what'll probably
happen is is they'll just call that out he'll
either already be in the MCU at the beginning of
the movie with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine or they'll
be in the fox Marvel Universe and something will
happen and then during the course of the movie
they'll come to the MCU universe that's the beauty
of Deadpool movies is they can be ridiculous as
long as they call it out during the movie like as
long as he makes fun of it it's all cool we saw a
little bit of that during the She-Hulk finale but
I don't expect Deadpool to get quite that meta
like he does break the fourth wall but like she
broke the fourth wall and was talking to a real
life Kevin foggy figure like she broke into real
life so her epic fourth wall break turned into
almost a fifth wall break and I don't think the
Deadpool will take it quite that far but talking
more about Namor in the MCU they are changing
Atlantis to talocan they pronounce it little bit
differently between some of the characters in
Black Panther so we'll see it's based a little bit
more on Aztec and Mayan mythology I think the idea
is that when you talk about like the big history
of the MCU we saw a little bit of that during the
eternals movie at some point some tragedy befell
the Aztec and the Mayan Empires and portions of
their people just broke off informed this other
talocan city and eventually that descended beneath
the waves but if it wasn't clear the whole idea is
that they're meant to be an advanced City that's
been hidden from the world just like wakanda
so for the most part they're like an underwater
version of wakanda and the really cool thing the
producers actually revealed about is some of the
actors is they're treating it a little bit like
a mob movie where you have two warring families
going at each other like obviously namor's family
in Black Panther's family it confirms some of my
theories about the dynamics of what's Happening
inside wakanda in the wake of t'challa's death
the beginning of the main plot picks up about a
year after t'challa's death they don't explain
exactly how he died but I believe it's meant to
be from some prolonged illness as far as I know
there's no giant twist and he wasn't accidentally
killed by name or anything like that as far far as
we know namor doesn't really get involved with
the wakana characters in The Plot until all the
Riri Williams the underwater vibranium the people
discovering talukan and all the Doctor Doom stuff
that's going on in the background in all the
scenes of ramanda inside the United Nations I
think has something to do with the rest of
the world coming for their vibranium like
why haven't you revealed yourself before this
you have all this advanced technology you could
help the world why aren't you sharing everything
with us so it's a lot of that real energy of the
world just being very greedy for her vibranium
and the Rumor right now is that Dr Doom is going
to be behind this big vibranium plot like he's
the one that kind of sets the conflict off and
he's really the one pulling the strings just like
all the other people in the world that want their
hands on vibranium he wants it too for himself
he's a man of magic and a man of technology
in the comics the Doom War Arc is basically
him invading wakanda to try and steal their
vibranium fun fact too shuri became the Black
Panther right after that Arc just like it seems
she's going to be in this movie but I think part
of the idea is that you have this research team
hired by Doctor Doom to find vibranium on the
ocean floor like underwater vibrating deposits
and while that's happening they just happen to
discover telecan and that's what sets things off
like once they've been discovered namor becomes
worried that the rest of the world will come for
his people the way that they're coming for wakanda
so I think the idea is that they wind up fighting
the wakandas like you have this big Invasion
happening like it is in the comics because Namor
blames Riri Williams Because she developed the
technology that allowed the research team to find
his City and shuri rabanda the other wakandans
wind up protecting Riri Williams like you see
her in all of shury's labs here so the way namor
treats it is that the friend of my enemy is also
my enemy and that's why he comes for them I made
the Captain America Civil War comparison in the
past because Bucky is blamed for the death of
Black Panther's father so black panther wants
to come for Bucky Captain America protects him so
you have a situation where black panther winds up
fighting Captain America and it divides the
entire Avengers this time the difference is
that it's mostly self-contained to the Black
Panther characters like from the first Black
Panther movie in all of namor's characters and
through that concept they introduced to Dr Doom
is behind everything pulling strings like the
whole idea that Baron Zemo was pulling strings
in Captain America Civil War Dr Doom is that
person in Black Panther wakanda forever but
I'm not expecting them to actually show him on
screen like I don't know that they've actually
cast an actor for MCU Doctor Doom what they
might do is just mention his company or his
name and then he'll show up in an actual Marvel
phase five project in the future I also think the
idea is that during the MCU Fantastic Four movie
in Marvel Phase 6 Doctor Doom is not meant to be
the main villain of that either just because they
don't want to repeat plot that they've done before
and they've done Dr Doom as the villain in all the
previous Fantastic Four movies The other big thing
you may have heard about is the idea they might
introduce Black Panther's son through the movie
like he might wind up having a son with Nokia
that we don't actually learn about till the end
of the movie or at some point during the movie a
lot of questions about that he does have a son in
the comics his name is Azari but his son is with
storm so he gets both her mutant powers like he
control the weather like storm can and he also
becomes the next Black Panther they might play
with that idea during the movie like there's a
lot of questions about them passing the costume
between a couple different people I believe that
shuri is meant to be like the New Black Panther
after the events of this movie but she won't
always be the Black Panther I think the idea
is that when his son comes of age Black Panther's
son will become the next Black Panther but because
the way the timeline moves like how old is
his son going to be during the movie because
Nakia clearly doesn't look pregnant and if he's
been dead for a year already his son would have
already had to have been born at some point before
his death because we didn't see Nakia right after
the events of Avengers end game like we just saw
black panther with his family what might wind up
happening is they just say that she was pregnant
during the blip and the son was born during the
blip I know a lot of people are asking about them
doing Young Avengers because we have ironheart in
this movie we just got scar son of Hulk he
seems like a prime Young Avengers character
we have a Hulk and if they're introducing Black
Panther's son he's going to become the future
black panther wouldn't he also join the Young
Avengers team so we're talking Marvel Phase 6
or after Marvel Phase 6 but I do think that they
will eventually do Young Avengers like it seems
stupid for them to not try to do it if he spotted
any of their Easter eggs and references in the
footage that I didn't talk about in the trailer
just write down below in the comments and I'll do
more black panther videos as we get closer to the
movie coming out everyone click here for my house
the Dragon episode 9 video and click here for my
other big black panther wakanda forever trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!